Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
- Une visite éclair qui n'était
pas prévue : Antony Blinken
se rendait à Munich po
une conférence. À la dernière
minute, il est allé à New York
pour s'adresser au Conseil
de sécurité de l'ONU.
"Je suis ici non pas
pour déclencher la guerre,
dit-il, mais la prévenir."
C'est que la tension
monte entre les deux pays.
Moscou a expulsé le numéro 2
de l'ambassade américaine sans
raison, selon les États-Unis.
Au même moment, la Russie
remet une lettre à Washington
où elle dénonce le nombre
alarmant de militaires
de l'OTAN à sa frontière.
Le secrétaire d'État ne mâ
pas ses mots : il prévient
que Moscou est en train
de manufacturer un prétexte
pour envahir l'Ukraine.
"Ça pourrait être un soi-disant
dedededement terroriste fabriqué
en Russie, dit-il, la découverte
d'une fosse commune inventée,
une attaque de drones contres se
ou réelle attaque chimique."
Depuis le début,
Washington publie toutesles infe
celles jugées confidentielles
du service de renseignement.
Selon le Pentagone,
ils seraient 150 000 militaires
russes amassés à la frontière
ukrainienne.
"Ils ont augmenté
leurs effectifs militaire,
dit-il. La menace est
très élevée. L'invasion russe
en Ukraine pourrait arriver
dans quelques jours."
Pour cet ancien ambassadeur
américain en Ukraine,
Washington défend des principes
fondamentaux d'intégrité
territoriale, mais qu'il y a
aussi un message pour la Chine.
"Si les présidents Putin et Xi
pensaient que la débâcle en
Afghanistan était une indication
que les États-Unis se retirent
de leur responsabilité,
la crise en Ukraine démontre
que nous ne reculons pas."
Et selon William Taylor,
il faut que l'Europe arrête
de dépendre du gaz russe.
"La Russie n'est pas
un fournisseur d'énergie fia
dit-il. C'est une erreur pour
l'Europe d'en dépendre."
La Russie affirme qu'elle
n'a pas l'intention d'envahir
l'Ukraine, mais qu'elle va
prendre ce qu'elle appelle des
mesures militaires techniques.
Ici, à la Maison-Blanche,
Joe Biden affirme que, malgré
tout, la voie diplomatiq